tous
plus d'appels au meurtre dans les rues
de paris sous peine de poursuites
judiciaires
la réaction du premier ministre au
lendemain des manifestations contre
l'écrivain rush doux léger accès de
fièvre sur les prix rose de 0,4 pour
cent le mois dernier
mort suspecte dans un hôpital de lyon la
famille porte plainte les conditions
d'hygiène serait en cause
les pays les plus riches
inquiet de la qualité de notre
environnement une première enquête en
alsace victimes des pluies acides
monsieur bonsoir et pardon de vous avoir
délaissé quelques temps la liberté de
manifester et de s'exprimer
même quand elle peut comme chez nous
librement s'épanouir à ses limites
il n'est plus question d'entendre comme
hier en plein paris des appels au
meurtre qui visait précisément en la
personne de l'écrivain salman rushdie la
liberté de pensée tel est le sens du
communiqué publié tout à l'heure par
l'hôtel matignon et développé lors d'une
conférence de presse par le président
mitterrand
patricia cost la loi de la république
française contre la loi islamique
il sera désormais interdit comme cela
s'est passé hier à paris de proférer des
phrases comme celle ci
mise en garde solennelle du premier
ministre tout nouvel appel à la violence
ou au meurtre sous quelque forme que ce
soit
donnera lieu à la mise en oeuvre
immédiate de poursuites judiciaires
françois mitterrand a personnellement
apporté sa caution au premier ministre
on se réunit on protestent c'est normal
on menace de mort d'autres choses nous
voulons concilier nos lois il attend que
ce qui est permis et ce qui pourrait ne
pas l'être
l'émotion suscitée par la violence de
ces images a aussi incité le mrap
association contre le racisme a porté
plainte
une manifestation comme celles là sont
peut-être de nature à susciter des
réactions racistes ou xénophobes dont
nous n'avons pas besoin
il faut lutter il faut empêcher toute
dérive
la seule façon de combattre ces dérives
c'est de faire respecter les principes
tous les principes la provocation au
meurtre est puni par la loi et le mans a
bien demandé aujourd'hui même au
ministre de la justice d'ouvrir une
information et de poursuivre ceux qui
seront reconnus comme moteurs de cette
provocation merde mais le mrap eux
refuse que son action contre les
fanatiques soit interprétée comme une
attaque contre l'ensemble de la
communauté musulmane
de son côté sos racisme appelle à
manifester mercredi prochain à paris
pour défendre la liberté d'expression
nouvelles manifestations meurtrières
toujours à propos de salman rushdie dans
le monde musulman un morts à karachi la
nuit dernière le gardien pakistanais du
centre culturel britannique un mort
encore et sept blessés au cachemire à
moscou où la sphère rochdi n'a à ce jour
provoqué aucun commentaire officiel
quelques intellectuels ont manifesté
aujourd'hui leur soutien à l'écrivain
britannique et à paris le président
mitterrand recevait aujourd'hui le
premier ministre britannique mal un tas
de chair une rencontre au sommet
imprégné on peut le dire déversés
satanique balance al cheikh a insisté
sur la rupture de fait les relations
diplomatiques entre londres et téhéran
se félicitant cette occasion que la
solidarité européenne
un très très bon saut mais selon les
participants qui on considère qu t d
autres dossiers européens en cours
l'hôpital présente il aujourd'hui un
risque supplémentaire pour le malade
la question paraît paradoxal dans un
pays comme le nôtre qui dispose sans
doute du meilleur réseau hospitalier du
monde et pourtant elle se pose de façon
grave et douloureuse à lyon le service
d'hématologie de l'hôpital edouard
herriot a été partiellement évacué une
jeune femme atteinte de leucémie est
morte brutalement et son mari a porté
plainte
a lyon claude réjean dans les quinze
derniers jours 11 cas suspects de
pneumopathies ont été détectés dans ce
pavillon d'hématologie un service où
sont traitées des leucémiques des
malades aux défenses immunitaires
affaiblies et donc très sensible aux
infections
c'est ici qu'une jeune femme est morte
samedi matin il y a beaucoup de travaux
en ce moment aux portes même du service
beaucoup de travaux donc beaucoup de
poussière un abri privilégié pour un
champignon l'aspergillus ce germe se
moque semble-t-il des portes de service
fermées l'aspergillus a été formellement
identifié dans deux cas d'infection sur
les onze recensés seuls deux résultats
sont prouvés battu logiquement sur les
onze malades
qui est présentée une pneumopathie ces
deux cas sont positifs en aspergillus
l'aspergillus qu'est ce que c'est parce
que j'ai lu c'est un champignon qui peut
se trouver dans l'environnement
mais les malades d'hématologie comme
tous les malades immunodéprimés sont
beaucoup plus fragiles pour ce germe
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il ya des
travaux il y à un danger accru pour ces
malades
il y a en effet un danger accru quand il
ya des travaux
nous avons suspendu actuellement les
travaux pour analyser notamment avec
l'architecte qu'il est possible de faire
et nous avons aussi bon l'instant
suspendu les consultations et l'activité
de l'hôpital de jour rien ne permet de
dire que le champignon l'aspergillus est
la cause de la mort d'une malade mais
pour en savoir plus sa famille a porté
plainte aujourd'hui la suspicion
d'infection puisqu'on ne peut pas parler
d'épidémie entraîné néanmoins affirmé
tueur du service et le transfert de 20
malades vers d'autres unités
hospitalières yonnaise jouer deux
questions viennent tout de suite à
l'esprit de question que je pose
responsable de l'hygiène publique a à
l'assistance publique de paris docteur
vaucaire bonsoir un tel risque
d'infection dans certains secteurs
hospitaliers il faut bien insister pas
dans tous est-ce que ce n'est pas un peu
la rançon du progrès au moment où
l'usagé des antibiotiques se banaliser
au moment aussi où l'on pratique très
volontiers des interventions disons
chirurgicale oui tout à fait il est sûr
qu'avec le développement de la chirurgie
qui est je veux dire aujourd'hui tout à
fait plus performantes l'hôpital
qu'accomplit il faut bien le dire quand
même des prouesses techniques
exceptionnelles les services de
réanimation qui se sont multipliés là
aussi pour accomplir des gestes
techniques plus audacieux mais aussi
plus à risque tout se tous ces progrès
extraordinaire des vingt dernières
années se sont soldées c'est vrai par un
accroissement des risques en particulier
des risques infectieux
car bien entendu tous ces gestes ne sont
pas anodins
vis-à-vis de l'affection alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire docteur dans ces
hôpitaux parce qu'on imagine que ces
bactéries sont plus en plus sophistiqués
si l'on peut dire de plus en plus
difficile à combattre
alors effectivement lusage très
important des antibiotiques qui nous ont
permis de combattre ces infections qui
ont rendu des services extraordinaire
pendant 20 ans et bien ont aussi eu un
effet de sélection sur les germes et les
microbes que l'on comptera l'hôpital
font des ronds sont des microbes qui
sont plus virulents plus difficiles à
traiter et donc l'infection hospitalière
il faut bien comprendre qu'elle est à la
fois tu reviens sur les organismes plus
réceptifs sur des malades affaibli et en
même temps avec des germes plus
virulents plus dangereux plus difficile
à combattre
et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
revenir à une hygiène encore plus
strictes je crois d'abord qu'il faut
revenir à des principes de base
d'hygiène que l'on a peut-être un petit
peu trop négligée
on a peut-être cru qu'avec les
antibiotiques tout était réglé les
antibiotiques il faut bien sûr les
conserver mais il ne faut pas pour
autant négliger l'hygiène hospitalière
il faut que nous ayons des hôpitaux
propres j'allais dire impeccable ils ne
sont pas l'un des câbles et il faut le
reconnaître ils ne sont pas suffisamment
propre il faut rééduquer tout le monde
voudrait aussi rééduquer parfois le
public qui n'hésite pas à laisser
traîner n'importe quoi n'importe où mais
il faut aussi éduquer ou rééduquer le
personnel à des gestes d'hygiène simples
car on ne peut pas faire l'économie de
la propreté de l'hygiène pour combattre
l'infection doctor who care mercy
détente sociale en tout cas dans les
milieux hospitaliers où les médecins
vous le savez menacé de faire grève
les propositions du ministère de la
santé paraissent plutôt satisfaisante
aux syndicats qui pourrait suspendre
leur préavis de mercredi prochain
un portrait robot pour résumer l'horreur
à metz les policiers recherchent
minutieusement la piste de l'assassin
violeur d'une petite fille de 3 ans sur
place dominique verdeilhan depuis la fin
de l'après-midi circule dans les locaux
de
police judiciaire de metz un portrait
robot celui de l'assassin présumé de la
petite christelle il représente un homme
de 40 ans 1 m 80 corpulence moyenne
cheveux bruns michaud teint mat un
portrait robot non diffusées
publiquement pour l'instant qui a été
établie à partir des nombreuses gardes à
vue effectuées depuis hier et à partir
de nombreux témoignages ce matin le
procureur de la république s'estimait
optimiste confiant mais réservés j'ai
espoir que notre eau
j'ai confiance question plus difficile
car il ne s'agit pas d'abord il ne
s'agit pas seulement de trouver
il s'agit aussi de prouver non ils sont
entendus
ce n'est pas un interrogatoire il y a
des gardes à vue
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
pour viol et homicide volontaire si
aucune thèse n'est écartée ce soir celle
d'un voleur pris d'une pulsion sadique
et privilégier un exhibitionniste aurait
déjà importunait de jeunes enfants
dernièrement un travail de fourmi pour
les enquêteurs mais aussi une course
contre la montre
on ne souhaite pas ici assisté sur le
plan politique un véritable dérapage et
ce à quelques jours des municipales ce
matin dans un communiqué à metz le front
national a réclamé le rétablissement de
la peine de mort en 1986 à metz deux
jeunes garçons de huit ans avaient été
assassinés par un adolescent de 17 ans
il y à un mois jour pour jour
ce dernier a été condamné à la réclusion
à perpétuité
oui et charles pasqua l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur qui était à metz pour
soutenir le candidat rpr donc aux
municipales chant pasqua a déclaré tout
à l'heure qu'il faudra bien je le cite
songer à un certain moment à rétablir la
peine de mort il a ajouté qu'il ne
fallait pas pour autant raisonner
uniquement en fonction de ce qui s'est
passé à metz la bourse a le hoquet à
paris baisse de 1,75 pour cent
aujourd'hui soit une baisse de plus de
5% en une semaine les investisseurs
craignent toujours la hausse des taux
d'intérêt dans le monde mais ils ont
bien accueilli un indice des prix de
janvier qui s'avèrent meilleurs que dans
d'autres pays comme l'allemagne
légère tendance à la hausse pourtant en
janvier puisque les prix à la
consommation en france ont augmenté de 0
4%
restons vigilants recommande donc pierre
bérégovoy claire chazal petite
accélération de la hausse des prix
français en janvier avec un indice de 0
4% le mois dernier contre 0 2% en
décembre l'inflation annuelle atteint
maintenant 3 3%
cela dit les prix flambent partout dans
le monde et davantage qu'en france en
allemagne et notamment l'inflation a été
le mois dernier beaucoup plus forte que
chez nous et elle est aujourd'hui de 2,6
pour cent sur un an
il y entre la hausse des prix français
et la hausse des prix allemands une
différence 0 27%
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis décembre
alors soyons vigilants nous avons une
hausse de 0 4%
parce que l'augmentation des taxes sur
les produits pétroliers il ya une petite
hausse des produits alimentaires les
produits manufacturés se tiennent bien
et quant au service même s'il augmente
un peu moins vite qu'il y a quelques
mois ils ne sont pas encore arrivés au
niveau que je souhaite donc il faut que
les français soient vigilants la france
est en train de remporter une grande
victoire sur l'inflation
elle doit rester parmi les meilleures
interprétation plutôt contradictoire
donc en somme c'est bien mais c'est
inquiétant alors expliquez nous ça
philippe sassier si nous étions sur un
terrain de football on pousserait quand
même un petit cocorico
parce que quand même la france faisant
mieux que l'allemagne va c'est un petit
peu le monde à l'envers
une bonne surprise qui s'explique ainsi
en allemagne par les os traditionnel de
ce début d'année puis par une
augmentation exceptionnelle de tva et en
france et bien par le bon fonctionnement
des mécanismes de concurrence et par la
très grande sagesse des salaires alors
pourquoi cet appel à la vigilance c'est
bien un peu partout claire chazal a
dealé le poussée de fièvre
inflationniste en angleterre aux
etats-unis notamment
et pour le moment les prix français
restent assez calme n'ont pas encore
répercuté à la hausse le pétrole le
dollar et les matières premières aux que
l'on enregistre depuis quatre mois mais
les produits industriels vont
probablement il réagi
prochain indices sont donc plus chahutés
il sera très difficile de respecter
cette année la hausse des prix de 2 2 %
affichée dans le budget par le
gouvernement cette hausse se situera
plutôt dans la fourchette 3 % à 3 5%
c'est à dire à peu près le chiffre de
l'an passé natation serait maîtrisée
mais tout dérapage plus important
relancerait leurs revendications
salariales à ce moment là c'est la
croissance économique l'emploi le franc
qui serait à nouveau menacée voilà qui
explique que ce soir pierre bérégovoy
dans une main une coupe de champagne
puis dans l'autre une grosse bouteille
de vigilance c'est un liquide de quelle
couleur vert conséquence en tout cas une
première conséquence de la hausse des
prix le smic devrait augmenter de 2,1
pour cent dès mercredi prochain
le mensuel brut atteindra donc 4961
francs 84 accalmie sur le front
hospitalier je vous disais tout à
l'heure tension en revanche dans des
milieux enseignants demain le ministre
de l'éducation lionel jospin doit
rencontrer à nouveau les syndicats que
ces propositions le sait ne satisfont
pas et qui re min aussi la menace
brandie vendredi dernier par michel
rocard de retirer purement et simplement
le plan jospin à côté des syndicats des
mouvements de coordination sont en train
de s'organiser
c'est ce qu'a constaté chantal kimmerlin
énoncé salle pour nous répondre
c'est le cadre des négociations et c'est
pour ça qu'on demande le projet le
retrait du projet the sparrow car même
si dans ce projet il ya un certain
nombre d'intentions qui sont bonnes
alors selon vous tous le projet jeu
sparrow car il faut faire table rase et
recommencer bruit
syndiqués ou non syndiqués 60% des
enseignants de ce lycée de la banlieue
parisienne ont rejoint la coordination
des enseignants en colère la greffe
totale et reconductible à partir de
demain et voter mon moyen de me
reconnaître
c'est de me trouver dans un groupe de
gens qui ne soit pas nécessairement les
syndicats d'autre part je trouve quant à
moi que les syndicats ne vont pas assez
loin dans leurs revendications
il continue à négocier dans un cadre que
nous l'acceptons pas revendications
retrait du projet jospin 2500 francs de
plus pour tous et par moi immédiatement
25 élèves maximum par classe des 70 89
revendications irréalisables dans le
cadre du budget actuel s'il était
proposé pour la revalorisation ces 2,2
milliards de francs
cela concerne à peu près 800 mille
personnes en activité et la condition
qu'on exclut les retraités et longues à
se poser des questions mais il y a qu'à
faire la division ça fait de l'ordre de
150 ou 200 francs par tête de pipe et
par mois encore isolées il ya quelques
semaines les coordination d'enseignants
commencent à se regrouper et à se
multiplier paris-banlieue nancy lille
brest et montpellier dur je pense que la
plupart des profs syndiqués ou non ici
seront tentés beaucoup plus par une
action de coordination que syndical si
les indications et position actuelle
c'est-à-dire une négociation dans un
cadre qui est inacceptable
demain après-midi les coordination
d'enseignants ne seront pas à la table
des négociations avec lionel jospin mais
s'exprimeront dans la rue lionel jospin
qui sera demain matin à 7 heures 45
l'invité de gérard morin aux 4 vérités
détente sur le front des prisons le
mouvement des surveillants de prison a
pratiquement cessé aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs régions du pays malgré l'appel
à la remobilisation qu'avait lancé le
syndicat fo pénitentiaire
le dépôt de bilan était intervenue en
juin 86 et bien le calendrier a été
respecté
le tribunal de commerce de paris a
prononcé cet après midi la liquidation
judiciaire de la norme aide qui regroupe
les chantiers navals de la seyne de la
ciotat est de dunkerque la cgt n'entend
pas baisser les bras pour autant
nicolas jacobs
il y a déjà plusieurs mois que les grues
du chantier de la ciotat ne fonctionne
plus pour ce chantier comme pour les
deux autres sites de la norme est de la
scène et dunkerque
cette décision marque la fin d'une
agonie qui dure depuis 82 près de onze
mille employés il y a dix ans il n'en
reste aujourd'hui que 250 répartis sur
les trois chantiers
les carnets de commandes sont vides
depuis longtemps l'état ne verse plus de
subventions depuis 86 aucun repreneur
n'a été jugé suffisamment sérieux
la décision de liquidation judiciaire
était prévisible à la ciotat pourtant la
cgt entend s'y opposer
pour nous de toute maniére l'action mais
le continue et même si l'axiome que nous
avons engagé avec occupation peut être
considérée comme illégale
aujourd'hui nous considérons notre
manière commune ont toujours considéré
que c'est une action légitime l'action
s'est depuis quatre mois le blocage du
dernier navire construit par le chantier
ce sera aussi mercredi une manifestation
des derniers normes aide avant dernière
semaine de campagne
le climat des municipales s'échauffent
et d'abord à marseille bien sûr bernard
tapie tout nouveau député soutiendra
donc robert vigouroux
ce qui n'est pas vraiment une surprise
sauf pour le parti socialiste qui
affirment officiellement tout à l'heure
qu'il n'est qu'il n'a pas choisi la
bonne carte
les réactions à marseille avec patrice
voler un soutien à robert buigues mais
sans participation directe bernard tapie
n'ira pas sur ces listes mais fera
campagne là choisi le camp du maire
sortant
parce qu'il est dit il le mieux placé à
gauche sur le terrain de son élection
législative
il soutiendra charlie milo un des barons
du socialisme marseillais qui lui a
ouvert les portes de la politique locale
en juin puis en janvier dernier bien sûr
je les aider avec john était tout seul
pas marché mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
tous les amis et qui est derrière lui et
je crois qu'il ya une part de
reconnaissance un mauvais coup de plus
pour michel peser ce matin il a refusé
de le commenter
pour ne parler que de son programme
économique priorité au port comme
bernard tapie
mais pour jean jacques queyranne porte
parole du ps le
l'om n'a pas tenu ses promesses de
neutralité fait avant sa victoire 2
janvier au conseil régional jean claude
gaudin préfère se consacrer à sa
campagne
ce soir avec le soutien de valéry
giscard d'estaing comme si l'engagement
de bernard tapie sur le terrain
municipal n'était que péripétie sans
surprise dans la campagne en cours
autre cas de figure originale au mans là
deux listes communistes vont s'affronter
celle du maire sortant qui n'est ni
reconstructeurs n'irait novateur mais
qui a péché aux yeux de son parti en
négociant seul avec le ps
et puis bien sûr une liste orthodoxe
pour une ou roger petit il s'affiche
partout mais se veut discret il veut
être réélu maire mais ne veut pas faire
campagne
retranché dans sa mairie du mans robert
jarry cultive le paradoxe excommunié
exclu du parti communiste pour avoir
conclu seul un accord électoral avec les
socialistes qui le soutiennent on le dit
hérétiques
lui se dit communiste je reste
communiste sans carte et il est bien
évident ce qui compte c'est les axes et
pas se déclarer comme l'y sabarat
comportement comme unies c'est-à-dire
d'abord et tolérant tolérant les
orthodoxes du pc estime n'avoir été trop
longtemps avec robert jarry des
orthodoxes qui cultivent eux aussi le
paradoxe pour combattre les rhétiques
ils ont désigné daniel boulet qui fut
dix ans l'adjoint de robert jarry à la
mairie c'est lui qui instruit le procès
en sorcellerie socialiste du maire je
crois qu'on peut avoir beaucoup
d'inquiétude de voir dans la liste
socialiste conduite par robert jarry une
très nette majorité de candidats
socialistes jarry l'hérétique est donc
condamné à l'enfer socialiste mais la
guerre des églises communiste fait au
moins un heureux le candidat de
l'opposition il favorise le seul
candidat a mené une campagne à
l'américaine
photos à l'appui une débauche de moyens
qui impressionne pourtant encore un
paradoxe
jacques doriz n'attaque jamais robert
jarry ils préfèrent plutôt qu'augmenter
les querelles théologiques communiste et
règlements le triste privilège d'avoir
deux listes communistes vous avez
monsieur jarry qui a créé une nouvelle
race de communisme serré communisme ça
retour en opposition à des communistes
orthodoxes
puis les communistes rénovateurs les
communistes de la pète rose pérestroïka
cela nous fait vraiment tout un
achalandage de communisme au monde
achalandage communiste ou non si robert
jarry réélu le mans aura sa tête un
maire qui se proclament communiste
combattu par les communistes mais
soutenu par les socialistes est
confrontée à une droite bonenfant en
apparence autant de paradoxes
mais qui sait désormais au mans tout est
possible
la protestation est spectaculaire la
détermination celle du désespoir
les déchirements internes de la
yougoslavie peuvent nous paraître bien
étranger mais le mouvement des trains
sans mineurs d'origine albanaise qui se
terre depuis dix jours au fond de leur
mine mérite qu'on s'y arrête avec éric
perrin en grève depuis dix jours un 1000
mètres sous terre
les 1300 mineurs albanais de 13 cas dans
le kosovo une province du sud de la
yougoslavie réclame la démission du
numéro un du parti
ils l'accusent de trahir les intérêts
des albanais et de favoriser l'extension
des pouvoirs de la serbie lors
république de tutelle la population
albanaise à 90% soutient activement le
mouvement
cette région est agitée depuis des
années par des conflits ethniques entre
serbes et albanais
le dissident fixant glisy avait son
invitation mais les services d'ordre
chinois l'ont empêché d'assister au
ventre est organisée hier par george
bush à pékin le président des états unis
avaient insisté pour que
l'astrophysicien surnommé par certains
le sakharov chinois soient présents
george bush a exprimé son regret en
prenant connaissance ce matin de
l'incident avant de s'envoler pour sa
dernière étape asiatique séoul
une visite qui a donné lieu à de
violentes manifestations janvier
américaine
l'enclavé de tabac sera de nouveau
égytienne après sept ans de querelles
l'israël et l'egypte ont finalement
conclu un accord qui prévoit la
restitution de tabac à l'egypte ce
territoire d'un kilomètre carré est une
station balnéaire le 15 mars
les troupes israéliennes laisseront leur
place aux policiers égyptiens
mais les israéliens pourront encore s'y
rendre pour une courte durée sans visa
faut-il interdire de vol les longs et
moyens courriers au delà d'un certain
nombre d'années de service
la question est sérieusement posée dans
les milieux de l'aéronautique
après la série d'accidents qui ont
frappé ces dernières semaines vous savez
les appareils boeing
dans le dernier cas à honolulu vendredi
dernier c'est le mécanisme de fermeture
de la soupe ce qui serait en cause
philippe dumez août 85 520 morts au
japon
un boeing 747 de la japan airlines s'est
écrasé à la suite de la rupture d'une
cloison à l'arrière de l'appareil
après cette catastrophe toutes les
compagnies possédant des 747
effectueront des contrôles pour déceler
d'éventuelles fissures et longtemps
découvrira un certain nombre avril 88
un boeing 737 faire une partie de son
toit en plein vol le pilote réussi un
atterrissage d'urgence
évitant une catastrophe seule une
hôtesse a été tuée janvier 89,1 autres
737 s'écrase en grande bretagne à la
suite d'un incendie dans un réacteur
trompé par une inversion des systèmes de
détection d'incendié
le pilote avait coupé le seul réacteur
en marche
bilan 44 morts le même mois
un avion du même type perd carrément un
réacteur au décollage
l'incident s'est produit aux états unis
et ne fait aucune victime
enfin vendredi dernier un boeing 747 de
united airlines perd un morceau de
carlingue à la suite semble-t-il de
l'ouverture intempestive d'une porte de
soute à bagages neuf morts les avions
civils
vieilli style prématurément c'est peu
probable mais en revanche ils sont de
plus en plus sophistiqués et peut-être
plus fragiles
l'entretien effectué par certaines
compagnies est il suffisant on peut se
poser la question
avec l'augmentation du trafic aérien
les personnels qualifiés commencent à se
faire rares peut-être faudra-t-il
rapidement il prend regarde pour éviter
des catastrophes encore plus grave
alerte à l'environnement la
préoccupation dans les pays les plus
riches n'est plus seulement celle des
écologistes patentés les gouvernements
s'en préoccupe enfin espérons qu'il
n'est pas trop tard
premier volet de l'enquêté lancée par
notre rédaction et nous emmène en alsace
et dans les vosges avec patrick esther
de même qu'il existe des gardiens de
phare cet homme est gardienne pollution
deux nuits par semaine il dort dans
cette tour d'acier de 50 mètres de haut
perdu au milieu des vosges 800 mètres
d'altitude
le col du donon un lieu privilégié pour
guetter les vents les températures mais
surtout les polluants atmosphériques
la tâche principale de ce technicien
faire en sorte que les capteurs
fonctionnent parfaitement 24 heures sur
par exemple il faut changer
régulièrement les filtres sur lesquels
se déposent les poussières nocives
les autres mesures prises de 10 mètres
d'altitude en dix mètres par des séries
de capteurs sont directement envoyées
vers un centre automatique
implantée à strasbourg mais pas besoin
d'être un expert pour constater qu'ici
au donon la forêt se meurt les arbres
perdent leurs aiguilles brûlé par les
pluies dont l'acidité est en constante
augmentation depuis 10 ans dans ses
serres expérimentales
certains arbres fraîchement plantés
subissent les effets de la pollution à 6
dans cette seconde serre d'autres arbres
plantés en même temps reçoivent de l'air
et de l'eau filtrée
leur croissance est pratiquement du
double mais les pollutions par là zot le
soufre les nitrates le gaz carbonique ne
s'attaque pas seulement à la végétation
même la pierre subi ces agressions
la pollution n'est pas le seul paramètre
qui rentrent en ligne de compte dans les
agents qui crée la dégradation mais
c'est l'un des paramètres c'est un
paramètre on pourrait dire amplifiant et
surtout accélérant des dégradations
si les pierres supporte mal les hommes
ne supporte plus du tout moi je me sens
très mauvais j'habite en plein centre
ville il ya des odeurs qui monte y
rentrer chez moi mais bon je sais pas
c'est
la fumée
roulant mobile est vraiment savez vous
avez un jeu mettait la main devant le
nez pour oeuvrer membres pas vraiment
rêves étouffés prises dans certains
quartiers les habitants ont réussi à
faire réduire de 15% leurs impôts locaux
en raison de la pollution qui y règne
est sale odeur la nuit qui nous dérange
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on dort on est réveillé
on doit fermer les fenêtres et ça
correspond aussi pour mon épouse qui
allait les yeux très souvent irrité et
ça depuis qu'on est à strasbourg
malheureusement pourtant globalement
dans cette ville les nuisances ont
diminué en 85 strasbourg était la ville
la plus polluée de france pour ce qui
concerne le soufre aujourd'hui le réseau
de surveillance automatique permet
d'affirmer que les rejets quotidiens
moyens ont été réduits de moitié en
quatre ans connaissant les niveaux de
pollution en permanence ça permet
d'intervenir dès l'instant où les
niveaux dépassent un seuil d'alerté fixé
de l'ordre de 250 microgrammes par mètre
cube de so2 par jour l'athée revenir
auprès d'industriels alors demandant de
réduire de moitié leurs émissions à la
raffinerie de reichstett en janvier
dernier l' alerte a été déclenchée
quatre fois ces jours là les gens
souffle et de l'est venant d'allemagne
un prêté pour un rendu certains jours
les français contaminent la forêt noire
sur les nuages polluer les frontières
n'existent pas ecosse france et en
football le 8 mars prochain à glasgow
on connaît maintenant les 18 joueurs
retenu par michel platini pour ce match
éliminatoire capital pour la
qualification en coupe du monde 90 vous
voyez patinier a notamment conservé
william prunier le défenseur auxerrois
à noter aussi les retours de jean tigana
et de josé touré en milieu de terrain et
les parisiens christian pérez et daniel
xuereb en attaque que ce n'est pas le
talent mais le génie qui a droit à être
dorée sur tranche le génie de la liberté
qui inspire la colonne de la bastille à
paris et qui retrouve son aspect
d'origine
j'en paye eux
le génie de la bastille comme vous ne
l'aviez jamais vu un jeune homme un vrai
jeune homme malgré ses 149 ans car cela
fait un siècle et demi depuis son
installation sur une musique d'hector
berlioz que l'oeuvre d'auguste à
d'humour dominent le paysage parisien
l'année du bicentenaire de la révolution
française notre génie méritait bien
qu'on lui redonne une seconde jeunesse
c'est derrière cette palissade que
s'opère la restauration de la statue
on a commencé ce matin à revêtir notre
génie d'une nouvelle peau une peau en or
sur la technique de la dorure à la
feuille michel pecqueur président d'elf
aquitaine qui patronnent l'opération et
jack lang ministre de la culture n'ont
pas hésité à se hisser à 50 mètres au
dessus du sol pour assister à
l'opération
la dorure payé par le mécénat constitue
la dernière étape de la restauration de
la colonne de la bastille et précédents
travaux ont permis de consolider le
monument est de refaire la patine du fus
budget global 3 millions de francs il
faudra attendre trois mois pour voir
réapparaître notre génie avec sa peau
dorée
en attendant chaque soir une flamme
entretenue par un brûleur spécial
témoignera de la présence de la statue
symbole de la liberté à mon temps avec
les pronostics de pirey bresse pour le
tiercé demain à enghien vous avez les
lire sur votre écran je l'espère né
voici le 14 le vin le 4 le 1 le 15 le
dise le 6 et le 11
dans un instant le temps avec laurent
cabrol qui nous reparlera de la tempête
qui a fait rage tout autour de la
méditerranée est aussi de la neige en
lozère et dans l'aveyron vos prochains
rendez vous avec l'information sur
antenne 2 c'est d'abord avec philippe
gassot tout à l'heure aux alentours de
minuit demain matin 6h 45 roger zabel et
son équipe 13 heures patricia charnelet
et william leymergie bien sûr merci
d'être fidèle à notre rendez-vous à
demain 20 heures